cuphead is one good-looking game and
under all that lovely animation lies a
difficult yet rewarding platformer and
if you're up to the task there are a
couple of secret modes ready and waiting
for you major major spoilers ahead so if
you'd rather keep the game a surprise
maybe check out some cuphead gameplay
first everyone else ready okay secret
sign if you've ever wondered what
cuphead would look like in its original
1930s form well there's a way to get an
even more authentic look than already is
if you talk to the turtle city on the
dock in inkwell aisle three he alludes
to a way to see the game in shades of
grey one that quote only a pacifist
platformer could see mysterious yes but
he's actually telling the truth you'll
have to go back to each of the
platforming levels and complete them
without firing a single shot from your
gun yes it's possible and you'll have to
use every ounce of your skill to do it
using the right combination of charms
and super arts you can avoid almost all
the enemies in the levels and make it to
the end of proud pacifists the smoke
bomb is incredibly useful here allowing
you to slip right past enemies unharmed
and the invincibility super will help
you circumvent some of the end bosses
you'll also be able to use your parry as
it's necessary in some parts to build
meter for your super so while you'll
probably end up killing things you can
just blame it on the enemies for getting
in your way you'll need to do this for
all six of Cup heads running good stages
fours Follies treetop trouble fun fair
fever fun house frazzle perilous peers
and rugged Ridge after completing a
pacifist run on a level you'll be
rewarded with the P rating the highest
honor in the game if you've got the
patience and managed to beat each one
without the use of your trusty
peashooter you'll be rewarded with the
game's black and white mode visit the
turtle again and he'll unlock the filter
options for you which includes the said
black and white option as well as a
vintage audio mode as if the game didn't
already sound old enough
it's a tough task for sure and for the
hardiest players it's a fitting way to
complete the true cuphead experience
okay you could just turn down the color
on your monitor but for those looking
for a true challenge this is it right
here but wait there's more in addition
to the black and white filter there's
also another filter you can get from the
fork standing outside the shop and world
3 he's only looking for grade-a people
which means that you might need to score
a's on every boss but even with some B's
scattered on your checklist you might be
able to get on his good side talk to him
and he'll let you see the world the way
he sees it and grant you a filter with a
2 stripped limited color palette could
there be more secrets tucked away in
cuphead if you found anything leave it
in the comments below and make sure to
check out GameSpot's review of cuphead
while you're at it
my name is Joey and thanks for watching
[Music]